.
PETER DOOCY LIVE ON THE NORTH
LAWN.
PETER, THANKS.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL EARLY.
HAROLD FORD JR., MOLLIE
HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR AT "THE
FEDERALIST" AND BILL BENNETT
FORMER EDUCATION SECRETARY AND
HOST OF THE BILL BENNETT SHOW
PODCAST.
BILL, START WITH YOU.
YOU HEARD JENNIFER'S REPORT AND
PETER ABOUT REALLY WHAT CHANGED
TO PRODUCE THIS ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT THIS INVESTIGATION IS GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD TODAY?
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE PRESIDENT
SAW.
I FOUND INTERESTING IN THAT
REPORT, BY THE WAY, SOME
AGGRESSIVENESS ON THE PART OF
THE PRESS.
THEY PERHAPS HEARD THE SIREN
CALL OF OBJECTIVITY THAT THERE
CAN BE AGGRESSIVE QUESTIONING OF
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.
IF SO, I HOPE SO.
LOOK, WE DON'T KNOW WHAT HE
HEARD.
WE DO KNOW THERE WAS A VESTED
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IN DENYING
THE TRUTH OF ANYTHING DONALD
TRUMP SAID.
I MENTIONED THIS THE OTHER
NIGHT.
THE OTHER THING, OF COURSE, IS
THE STONEWALLING BY CHINA FROM
THE VERY BEGINNING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED AND HOW THIS OCCURRED.
NOW, IT WOULD BE GOOD IF THE
PRESIDENT WOULD PUSH PRESIDENT
XI A LITTLE BIT BUT YOU JUST SAW
IN YOUR REPORT, THAT THE WHITE
HOUSE WAS RELUCTANT TO ADMIT ANY
CONVERSATION HAD TAKEN PLACE.
LET'S TALK ABOUT WHAT WE DO
KNOW.
WE DO KNOW THAT THEY KNEW THEY
HAD A DEADLY VICE, WOULD NOT LET
THEIR OWN PEOPLE TRAVEL INSIDE
THEIR COUNTRY BUT WOULD LET THEM
GO OUT AND EXPORT THIS VIRUS TO
OTHER COUNTRIES.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE THEIR
CULPABILITY LOOK VERY GOOD.
THAT MAKES THEIR CULPABILITY
VERY LIKELY AND I THINK EVEN
OPENS THE POSSIBILITY OF IT
BEING MORE LIKELY THAT THEY HAD
SOMETHING TO DO WITH THE
ORIGINS.
SEEMS TO ME THE BURDEN OF PROOF
IS ON THEM GIVEN THEIR BEHAVIOR
ONCE THEY KNEW WHAT IT WAS THEY
WERE DEALING WITH; HOWEVER IT
WAS CREATED.
>> Bret: YEAH, WHICH WAS THE
CASE IN MARCH OF 2020, REALLY.
THAT EXACT FACT PATTERN AND THAT
EXACT FACT THAT THE U.S.
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS KNEW THAT
CHINA WAS COVERING IT UP WITH
EVERYTHING THEY HAD.
MEANTIME, BEIJING TODAY, TO
QUOTE THE "WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
BEIJING MEANWHILE TOLD AN ANNUAL
GATHERING OF THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION'S DECISION MAKING
BODY TUESDAY THAT IT CONSIDERED
THE INVESTIGATION AND ITS
COUNTRY TO BE COMPLETE AND SAID
ATTENTION SHOULD NOW TURN TO
OTHER COUNTRIES.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ARE GOING
TO LAUNCH THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATION OF WHERE THE
CORONAVIRUS STARTED, MOLLIE.
>> SWITZERLAND?
>> I THINK IT'S NOT JUST THAT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
COULDN'T HAVE DONALD TRUMP
HAVING SAID ANYTHING TRUE.
THE MEDIA REALLY PLAY A ROLE
HERE, TOO.
YOU JUST POINTED OUT, BRET, THIS
IS WHAT WE KNEW A YEAR AGO.
AND THE MEDIA THOUGHT THAT THERE
WERE TWO OPTIONS, BASICALLY YOU
CAN BLAME CHINA FOR HOW THEY
HANDLED THIS, YOU KNOW, VIRUSES
CAN COME FROM ANYWHERE, HOW YOU
HANDLE THEM IS KEY.
SO MANY PROBLEMS WITH HOW CHINA
HANDLED THIS.
EVEN IF YOU LEAVE ASIDE IT WAS
ALWAYS A STRONG POSSIBILITY THAT
IT CAME OUT OF THIS WUHAN
INSTITUTE OF VIROLOGY, THEY
COULDN'T LET DONALD TRUMP OR
MIKE POMPEO BE RIGHT.
SO THEY COULDN'T EVEN BE CURIOUS
ABOUT THOSE ORIGINS.
THIS IS A MASSIVE SCANDAL.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT AFFECTED
THE ENTIRE WORLD, HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE, YOU KNOW IT,
DESTROYED THE ECONOMY.
PUT SO MANY PEOPLE OUT OF WORK.
IT KILLED MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
IT SICKENED SO MANY PEOPLE.
THERE SHOULD BE GLOBAL FOCUS ON
JUST FINDING OUT WHAT HAPPENED
SO THAT IT CAN'T HAPPEN AGAIN.
HOLDING PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
WHAT MISTAKES WERE MADE.
YESTERDAY BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
SAYS THEY ARE JUST GOING TO LET
THE WORLD HEALTH ORGANIZATION
HANDLE IT WE ALREADY KNOW THEY
ARE TOO COMPROMISED BY CHINA
THAT WAS PART OF THE PROBLEM
LAST YEAR WHEN THEY WERE TAKING
WHAT CHINA SAID AND
REGURGITATING IT HOW THERE
WASN'T HUMAN-TO-HUMAN
TRANSMISSION AND DIDN'T NEED TO
WEAR MASKS AND HOW TRAVEL BANS
WEREN'T NECESSARY.
WE REALLY NEED PEOPLE TO THINK
THROUGH EVERYTHING HERE BUT WE
ALREADY KIND OF KNOW WHAT WE
NEED TO KNOW IN TERMS OF WHO IS
CULPABLE.
>> Bret: YEAH.
AS FAR AS CHINA'S TRANSPARENCY,
TAKE A LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WE HAVE HAD A TERRIBLE
FAILURE FOR 15 MONTHS TO
RECOGNIZE AS A PUBLIC AND
BROADLY AS A U.S. GOVERNMENT THE
PLAUSIBILITY OF THE LAB LEAK
POSSIBILITY AND THE HUGE
IMPORTANCE FOR FUTURE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND FOR FUTURE NATIONAL
SECURITY.
>> WE HAVE GOTTEN THIS QUESTION
ABOUT THE ORIGINS AND WE HAVE
BEEN PRETTY VOCAL, RIGHT, THIS
ADMINISTRATION, WE DIDN'T HAVE
ACCESS.
YOU KNOW, CHINA WASN'T
TRANSPARENT ENOUGH.
WE HAVE BEEN SAYING THAT FOR A
VERY LONG TIME.
>> THERE'S NO WAY THAT THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY IS GOING
IT TURN OVER ANY OF THE
INFORMATION THAT WILL BE NEEDED
IN ORDER TO HAVE A SERIOUS
INVESTIGATION.
>> Bret: HAROLD, SOME PEOPLE MAY
ASK WHY IS THIS IMPORTANT?
WHY DOES IT MATTER?
AND, IF CHINA IS SOMEHOW
CULPABLE OR COVERING UP WHAT WAS
A LAB ACCIDENT FROM THAT LAB,
THERE ARE A LOT OF QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHAT THAT MEANS
RETRIBUTION WISE.
BUT THEN THERE IS THE QUESTION
ABOUT HOW WE HAVE HANDLED IT AND
WE HAVE DISMISSED IT.
WHAT ELSE ARE WE DISMISSING?
>> WELL, IT'S GOOD TO BE ON WITH
YOU.
GOOD EVENING.
I THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE INVESTIGATION TO TAKE PLACE.
AND I AGREE WITH SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN SAID
ALREADY.
I THINK THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
IS ORGANIZING OUR ALLIES AND
PARTNERS AND EVEN SOME AROUND
THE WORLD THAT DON'T NECESSARILY
AGREE WITH US ALL THE TIME.
IF WE ARE ABLE TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF THIS WITH FACTS AND
ATTRIBUTE AND FIND OUT THE
ORIGINS OF HOW THIS STARTED THAT
CERTAINLY HELPS.
I GIVE DR. FAUCI A LOT OF CREDIT
FOR SAYING I MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
LITTLE WRONG.
I'M NOW WANTING TO CORRECT THAT
I THINK WE NEED MORE OF THAT IN
PUBLIC LIFE.
CERTAINFULLY POLITICS.
I WOULD ARGUE IN BUSINESS AS
WELL.
AND 90 DAY LIMIT THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS PUT AROUND, THIS
WHETHER OR NOT HE DISMISSED THIS
FROM THE BEGINNING BECAUSE OF
POLITICS, I DON'T KNOW, I DOUBT
THAT BECAUSE I KNOW HOW SERIOUS
AND EXPERIENCED HE IS IN FOREIGN
POLICY AND INTELLIGENCE MATTERS.
BUT, EVEN IF YOU BELIEVE
POLITICS PLAYED AT THE BEGINNING
OF THIS AND THIS PRESIDENT
DISMISSING INVESTIGATION BECAUSE
OF HIS FEELINGS OF THE FORMER
PRESIDENT.
YOU HAVE TO GIVE CREDIT FOR THIS
ADMINISTRATION SAYING NOW IS THE
TIME TO DO THIS RIGHT.
I DON'T SUBSCRIBE TO THAT
THEORY.
I THINK THIS IS THE RIGHT THING
TO BE COOKING.
AND I TAKE PRESIDENT BIDEN AT
HIS WORD WHEN HE WAS CANDIDATE.
HE SAID FROM THE OUTSET PETER
DOOCY'S REPORTING POINTED OUT HE
WOULD HAVE FIGURED OUT A WAY TO
GET INTO CHINA EARLY ON TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE ORIGINS WERE
AND WHAT THE WORLD NEEDED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT AND IF INDEED
THEY HAD SOME WAY TO CURE THIS
THAT THEY WERE HOLDING ON
THEMSELVES.
WE WILL FIND OUT AS THIS
INVESTIGATION UNFOLDS, I
BELIEVE.
>> Bret: BILL, LAST THING WE HAD
THIS MEDIA MONTAGE ALMOST A
MEDIA DIFFERENT FIGURES AND
MEDIA CALLING IT A CONSPIRACY
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING AND
POINTING BACK TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
FINAL WORD ON THIS?
THAT DOES HAVE AN EFFECT,
COLLECTIVELY ON A STORY LIKE
THIS THAT NOW THEY ARE ALL
HAVING TO KIND OF GO THE OTHER
WAY.
>> YEAH.
I DON'T SEE A LOT OF APOLOGIES
OUT THERE MEA CULPAS.
BUT THEY BETTER SURE GO THE
OTHER WAY BECAUSE AS MOLLIE
POINTED OUT.
YOU KNOW, YOU HAD A JOURNALIST
THE OTHER NIGHT ON THIS SHOW SAY
WELL, IF CHINA DID THIS ON
PURPOSE, THEY GOT A BLACK EYE.
THIS ISN'T A BLACK EYE.
THIS WAS A WORLD CATASTROPHE.
AND ALL ATTENTION NEEDS TO BE
FOCUSED HERE AND THE PRESS NEEDS
TO UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
IT AND LIVE UP TO THE STANDARD
OF THAT IMPORTANCE BY ITS O